já esteja por dentro mas quem quer como
irritar um jogador do moletom pode fazer
tudo o que quiser mas não tira disso
percebo o que o que é um perfeito porque
nunca que eu pensei pensei e é isto o
que irritou e se é isto está a ganhar
porque é ruim dos 10 ao assumir em 27 e
ver um dash começo porque ainda não é
mais o primeiro penso por que quem come
mais urbano
toda a gente sabe a sua parte miguel
monteiro conta do novo vai ser aqui a
pista será que dá pra jogar um pouco
mais do que na frente usar o comando é
bombeiro 24 estudar qual o que será que
está tudo a provar louca história deve
ser vista com isso não quer dizer livre
é porque o assumir do vídeo português
vhils eu preciso de visualizações miguel
visualizações joga só com um cavalo
testei o cavalo os manda a corda vai
colocar o rosto escondido atrás da
cadeira dos ganhos porque eu sou o
youtube
eu tenho defendido a minha defesa
protege me como está miguel monteiro of
stories num planeta existia coca-cola
gordura do adolescente para os tênis
também voa desculpa desculpa desculpa
miguel monteiro mulheres uma cadeira a
cadeia vai se vingar o ataque não foi
efetivo
o ranking é o regresso não quer saber
não entende nada disto porque eu entendo
esta vodafone morro lar o que o código
pin na hora
qual é a tua e do telemóvel desde o qual
é 91 92 93 escolas das mós
não seja agressivo miguel monteiro herói
eu sou chaves arduino aí vou planejar
ele não conhece o ataque charles ar
triste saber que o sharesafe miguel
monteiro jogos vou jogar pokémon gol é
melhor pokémon go um risco miguel montar
seu freezer miguel monteiro como é que o
faz vivo ainda 14 seu fim da fita não
merece viver merece morrer
alguma coisa se passou que faça miguel
monteiro agora vai obedecer miguel
monteiro vai julgar o louro brincar aqui
miguel monteiro é melhor jogar logo não
fique aí ficava vai ser portado eu
voltar a portar a pistola vai capotar e
parar na tua lata de spray na lata
já o próximo jogo miguel não tava 15
empresas pior agora a gente tá miguel
fica aqui com esse medo de sair para
mulher fazemos muitos lo muitos muitos
roupas morrer miguel monteiro bairro
[Risadas]
bola é tóxico moldes traga suplentes
miguel sorriso e pra mim tudo é jogar
disso irá nos ajudar os seus fortes
porque miguel monteiro devia usar os
seus fãs sempre em todo jogo isso mesmo
miguel agora tu merece uma festa uma
festinha senhora alguém está morto
alguém vai comprar e temos não só
estando morto como é possivel três
monitores não pode ficar assim
tabuleiro ouija será comigo é um demônio
meu deus vou sentir ela responderá nos
sentir a presença da única disse que sim
e não mereces beber sai demônio say say
say say demônio reino de jesus miguel
optimizar discórdia
a anima larga mal de são miguel monteiro
o certo é um demônio guarda o meu amigo
mas com meu amigo demônio paga essa
cadeira não existe miguel monteiro bar
miguel monteiro de sol deixando a equipe
favorito mas favorito disse adeus adeus
adeus à champions